This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In 2011, the race for U.S. president was heating up. Near the front of the pack, on the Republican side, was Rick Perry. His odds looked promising. He had been governor of Texas for more than a decade, and the previous Republican president, George W. Bush, had also been a Texas governor. Rick Perry's poll numbers were competitive and he had amassed an impressive war chest. His core themes of shrinking government and cutting spending were popular with many Republican voters.
这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。2011年，美国总统竞选正进入白热化阶段。在共和党阵营中，里克·佩里处于领先集团。他胜算很大。他担任德克萨斯州州长已超过十年，而上一任共和党总统乔治·W·布什也曾是德州州长。里克·佩里的民调数据很有竞争力，且筹集到了令人瞩目的竞选资金。他关于精简政府和削减开支的核心主张，深受许多共和党选民的欢迎。
Tonight, we are here in the great state of Michigan for a debate that will focus almost exclusively on the economy. On November 9, Rick Perry appeared on stage in Rochester, Michigan, along with seven fellow candidates. It was a live, televised debate, watched by millions. But the fact of the matter is we better have a plan in place that Americans can get their hands around, and that's the reason my flat tax is the only one... Rick Perry launched energetically into a description of the actions he planned to take as president
今晚，我们来到伟大的密歇根州，进行一场几乎完全聚焦于经济议题的辩论。11月9日，里克·佩里与七位候选人一同出现在密歇根州罗切斯特的舞台上。这是一场有数百万人观看的电视直播辩论。但事实是，我们最好制定一个美国人能够理解的计划，这就是为什么我的单一税制是唯一……里克·佩里充满活力地开始描述他计划在担任总统后采取的行动
and his sweeping plans to slash the size of government. Under his leadership, he vowed, entire departments would disappear. And I will tell you, it's three agencies of government when I get there that are gone. Commerce, education, and the... what's the third one there? Let's see. Commerce, education, and the... You can't name the third one? The third agency of government. I would do away with the education, the...
以及他削减政府规模的宏大计划。他发誓，在他的领导下，一些政府部门将不复存在。我告诉你们，当我上任后，有三个政府机构将被撤销。商务部、教育部，还有……第三个是什么来着？让我想想。商务部、教育部，还有……你连第三个都说不出来吗？第三个政府机构。我会撤销教育部，还有……
Commerce. And let's see I can't the third one I can't sorry oops that oops on national TV helps sink Rick Perry's presidential aspirations all of his careful preparation and fundraising came to nothing. His memory had betrayed him when he needed it most. The following year, former Massachusetts Governor Mitt Romney was chosen as the Republican Party's nominee for president. This week on Hidden Brain, the mysteries of memory. How it works, why it fails us, and how to build memories that stick. So much of daily life depends on our memories.
商务部。让我想想，我不能……第三个我不能……抱歉，哎呀。在全国电视直播中出现的这次失误，导致里克·佩里的总统梦碎，他所有的精心准备和筹款都付诸东流。在他最需要的时候，记忆背叛了他。次年，前马萨诸塞州州长米特·罗姆尼被选为共和党总统候选人。本周的《Hidden Brain》将探讨记忆的奥秘。它是如何运作的，为什么会让我们失望，以及如何建立持久的记忆。日常生活在很大程度上依赖于我们的记忆。
Getting to important events on time, remembering a friend's birthday, executing skills in the workplace. But our memories often don't work the way we wish. Even in the absence of neurological disorders, perfectly healthy people find they forget important things all the time. At the University of Virginia, psychologist Daniel Willingham has observed many lapses of memory in his own life. In his lab, he has studied different ways that our memory can fail us and how we can fix it. Dan Willingham, welcome to Hidden Brain.
准时参加重要活动、记住朋友的生日、在工作中运用技能。但我们的记忆往往不如我们所愿。即使没有神经系统疾病，完全健康的人也经常会忘记重要的事情。在弗吉尼亚大学，心理学家丹尼尔·威林厄姆观察到自己生活中也常有记忆缺失。在他的实验室里，他研究了记忆让我们失望的不同方式以及我们如何修复它。丹·威林厄姆，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。
Thank you so much. Happy to be here. Dan, when you were a college student, you enrolled in a course you were sure you were going to get an E.Z.A. in. What was this course, Dan? It was a physical anthropology course. I took this course solely because I thought it was going to be an easy A. And then it turned out eventually to be the lowest grade that I got in any college course.
非常感谢。很高兴来到这里。丹，当你还是大学生时，你选修了一门你确信能轻松拿A的课程。那是什么课，丹？那是一门体质人类学课程。我选这门课完全是因为我觉得它能轻松拿A。结果它最终成了我在大学所有课程中成绩最低的一门。
And did you, I'm assuming you must have gone and talked to the professor and tried to make your case as students are wont to do. I did. And I said exactly what today my students say to me. I said, you know, I'm very confused. You know, I'm certain that I knew this content very well, and yet I did very poorly on your test. So I'm here to try to figure out
我猜你一定去找教授谈过，试图据理力争，就像学生们常做的那样。确实。我说了今天我的学生对我说的同样的话。我说，你知道，我非常困惑。我确信我对这些内容掌握得非常好，但我在你的考试中却考得很差。所以我来这里是想弄清楚
how I can do better in your course, which is really polite double talk for. That was a terrible test. It was really unfair. This, of course, did not fool the professor in the least. And he said, so you feel like you knew the content. I said, yes, absolutely. He said, OK, well, so for example,
我怎样才能在你的课程中表现得更好，这其实是一种礼貌的委婉说法，意思是：那次考试太糟糕了，非常不公平。当然，这根本骗不了教授。他说，所以你觉得你掌握了内容。我说，是的，绝对掌握了。他说，好吧，那么举个例子，
we talked about different categories of stone tools. And you understand. Yes, I absolutely understand. OK, so why don't you tell me about the different categories of stone tools? So I sputtered a bit and then eventually said, well, I understand it. I just can't explain it. So there was sort of a mismatch between my perception
我们讨论了不同类别的石器。你理解吗？是的，我绝对理解。好吧，那你给我讲讲石器有哪些不同类别？我支支吾吾了一会儿，最后说，嗯，我理解，我只是解释不出来。所以，我对记忆的感知与我在考试背景下实际的记忆状况之间存在某种错位。你知道，心理学家有时称之为“解释深度的错觉”。我们以为自己懂了，但当被要求真正输出这些知识时，我们却力不从心。这种情况我们经常遇到，对吧，丹？确实如此。
of what my memory was like and what my memory was actually like in the context of the test. You know, so psychologists sometimes call this the illusion of explanatory depth. We think we know things, but when challenged to actually produce that knowledge, we come up short. And this happens all the time to us, right, Dan? It really does.
你以为判断自己是否掌握某件事的方法，就是审视一下自己的记忆，看看自己是否知道。但事实证明，我们做出这种判断的方式有很多种。所以，使用错误的线索来判断自己是否掌握某事，就是你会出错的原因之一。我想提出另一个案例，我认为它揭示了我们记忆让我们失望的另一种方式。大学毕业后，你去了心理学研究生院，有一天你的导师召集了一次非常重要的大型实验室会议。告诉我发生了什么。
The way you would think that you would judge whether or not you know something is really just sort of look at your memory and see whether or not you know it. But it turns out there are a number of different ways we make this judgment. And so that's one of the ways you can go wrong is using the wrong cue to decide whether or not you know something. I want to bring up another incident that I think reveals a different way in which our memories can fail us. So after college, you went on to graduate school in psychology and one day your advisor called a really big and important lab meeting one day. Tell me what can fail us. So after college you went on to graduate school in psychology and one day your advisor called a really big and important lab meeting one day. Tell me
发生了什么？是的，我的导师是一位杰出的心理学家。他实际上是国家科学奖章的获得者，但他相当令人敬畏。他以谈话中长时间的停顿而闻名，期间你必须假设他在思考，但你不知道他在想什么。所以是的，我们都很怕他。发生的事情是我忘记了会议，讽刺的是，会议就在我办公室门外的公共办公区举行。所以我当时关着办公室的门。我正愉快地读着书，或者我不知道当时在干什么。
what happened. Yeah, my advisor was a brilliant psychologist. He actually was winner of the National Medal of Science, but he was rather forbidding. He was sort of known for very long pauses during conversations, during which you had to assume he was thinking, but you didn't know what he was thinking. So yes, we were all pretty frightened of him. What happened was that I forgot about the meeting and the irony was that the meeting was happening in sort of a bullpen area right outside my office door. So I had my office door closed. I was happily, you know, reading or I don't know what in the world I was doing.
但实验室会议就在离我10英尺远的地方进行。我猜他们当时在说，威林厄姆去哪了？怎么回事？我完全不知道。所以是的，这就是心理学家所说的“前瞻性记忆”的失败，即你计划记住某事，而在这种情况下，显然是极其糟糕地没能记住它。我几乎不敢问，你的导师有没有找你谈过这件事？是的，我去找他谈了。我说了这件事之后，他回应前大概有20秒的停顿，期间我如坐针毡。他确实说，哦，没关系，这种事我们都会遇到，但这非常令人尴尬。
But the lab meeting was happening 10 feet away from me. And I expect they were saying, you know, where's Willingham? What's what? I just had no idea. So yeah, that's a failure of what psychologists call prospective memory, where you're planning to remember something, and in this case, obviously, failing dreadfully to remember it. I almost hesitate to ask, did you hear from your advisor about it? Yes, I went to talk to him about it. And yeah, the duration of the time between I said something about it and he responded was probably 20 seconds or something during which I was squirming. And he did say like, oh, it's okay, it happens
是的。现在我们很多人觉得有些记忆是不会出错的。当我们学好某样东西时，我们会觉得，好了，我掌握了。丹，在你教书的第一年，你向一班学生解释统计学的一个基本概念。你当时想教什么，告诉我发生了什么？是的，非常基础的东西，大概是开学第二周吧。我当时在教分布的偏度。所以你们的许多听众可能熟悉钟形曲线。
to all of us, but it was extremely uncomfortable. Yeah. Now lots of us feel that some memories are immune from lapses. When we learn something well we feel, okay, I've got this. In your first year of teaching, Dan, you were explaining a basic concept in statistics to a class of students. What were you trying to teach and tell me what happened? Yeah, very basic sort of like, it was probably the second week of class, I think. I was teaching about skewness of distributions. So many of your listeners probably are familiar with the bell-shaped curve.
曲线不仅可以是钟形的，还可以一端肥大，另一端细长。细长的那部分可能在左边，也可能在右边。这就是所谓的分布偏度。我们谈论分布时，会说它是正偏态还是负偏态，
So curves can not only be bell-shaped, they can be kind of fat at one end and then skinny at the other. And that skinny part might be on the left or on the right. And so this is referred to as the skewness of the distribution. And we talk about a distribution having either a positive or a negative skew,
取决于哪一边肥大，哪一边细长。而在教授这门本科课程时，我竟然卡住了，想不起来哪边是正，哪边是负。这再基础不过了。但是的，我就是忘了。当然，我越是努力去想，就越是不确定，它就是从我脑海中溜走了。所以，令人尴尬的记忆失败可能发生在
depending on which side is fat and which is skinny. And I could not, while I'm teaching this undergraduate course, I just blanked on which was positive and which was negative. And you can't get much more elementary than that. But yeah, I just lost it. And of course, the more I tried to think about it, the more uncertain I became, and it just evaded me. So, embarrassing failures of memory can happen
私下的小互动中，也可能发生在非常重大的公开舞台上。在某些情况下，这些记忆崩溃的代价可能远不止尴尬时刻。它们实际上可能是天文数字。我想请你听听这篇2021年的新闻报道。旧金山居民斯特凡·托马斯丢失了打开他数字钱包的密钥，里面存有7000枚比特币。
in small private interactions, and also on very big public stages. And in some cases, the costs of these memory breakdowns can be far worse than an awkward moment. They can actually be astronomical. I want you to listen to this news report from 2021. San Francisco resident Stefan Thomas lost the key to unlock his digital wallet that holds 7,000 bitcoins.
这相当于惊人的2.2亿美元。正确的密码锁在一个硬盘里，该硬盘给用户10次猜测机会，之后就会永久锁定。托马斯只剩下两次机会来获取他的财富。所以斯特凡·托马斯最终还是没能想起他的密码，丹。你能想象忘记一个通往巨额财富的密码是什么感觉吗？就像被锁在自己的生活之外。
That translates to a whopping $220 million. The correct password is locked in a hard drive that gives users 10 guesses before it locks forever. Thomas has only two more tries to gain access to his fortune. So Stefan Thomas never did remember his password, Dan. Can you imagine what it must feel like to not remember a password that leads to a gigantic fortune? It's like being locked out of your own life.
是的，我是说，我从未拥有过巨额财富，所以我有点在异想天开地想象它。但确实，我们在忘记密码方面都有过类似的经历。这些天每个人都会遇到这种情况。但令人震惊的是，他确信自己能记住这个密码。
Yeah, I mean, I've never had a gigantic fortune, so I am sort of, I'm getting a little fanciful here in imagining it. But yeah, certainly we've all been there in terms of forgetting passwords. This happens to everybody these days. But what is startling is his confidence that he was going to remember this.
我们对记忆的判断往往是错误的。令人震惊的是他确信自己能记住这个密码。我们对记忆的判断往往是错误的。斯特凡·托马斯并非个例。一些加密货币专家估计，全球约20%的比特币似乎都在丢失或以其他方式被困在钱包中。那么，为什么记忆在我们最依赖它的时候让我们失望呢？回来后，我们将探讨关于记忆运作方式的反直觉真相。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在弗吉尼亚大学，丹·威林厄姆
Our judgment of our memory is often faulty. Startling is his confidence that he was going to remember this. Our judgment of our memory is often faulty. Stefan Thomas is not alone. Some cryptocurrency experts estimate that around 20 percent of Bitcoin holdings worldwide appear to be in lost or otherwise stranded wallets. So why does memory let us down when we most depend on it? When we come back, counterintuitive truths about how memory works. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. At the University of Virginia, Dan Willingham
研究为什么我们的记忆会让我们失望，以及我们如何成为更好的学习者。丹，在我们生活的大多数领域，我们都相信我们的意图决定了结果。如果我足够渴望某件事，我就会采取行动让它实现。我明白，但你在读研究生时，第一次纠结于这个原则在记忆方面是否有效。我们想要记住某事的愿望有助于我们记住它吗？这很神奇。它实际上没有任何影响，因为有些事情我们真的很想记住。
studies why our memories fail us and how we can become better learners. Dan, in most domains of our lives, we all believe our intentions shape our outcomes. If I want something badly enough, I will take the steps to make it happen. I understand yet you were in graduate school when you first grappled with the question of whether this principle works when it comes to memory. Does our wanting to remember something help us to remember it? It is amazing. It has literally no impact at all in that there are things that we really want to remember.
例如，我们的比特币密钥，或者任何时候你遇到一个你非常想记住名字的人。当然，我们知道我们经常记不住。而且，你记得的很多事情，你根本没有任何意图去记住，更不用说有兴趣去记住了。没错。所以这应该给我们一点启示。实验室实验也证实了这一点。你可以告诉人们，听着，你的记忆稍后会被测试，或者不告诉他们。这对于他们最终是否记住某事没有任何影响。你知道，你刚才说了一件非常有趣的事情，那就是我们不仅记不住我们想记住的事情，
For example, the key to our Bitcoin or anytime you meet someone you would really like to remember their name. And of course, we know we very often don't. And then too, there are so many things that you remember that you never had any intention of remembering, much less have any interest in remembering. Right. So that should give us a little bit of a clue. And laboratory experiments back this up. You can tell people, listen, your memory is going to be probed later or not tell them that. And it has no impact on whether or not they eventually remember something. You know, you said something really interesting a second ago, which is that it's not just the case that we fail to remember things that we want to remember,
而且我们经常记得我们根本不在乎的事情。所以这里发生了一些非常奇怪的事情，那就是我们的记忆似乎并不遵循我们的意志或意图。在某种程度上，它们似乎有自己的想法。丹，大脑的本质是什么，使得我们记住某事的意图
but that we regularly remember things that we don't care to remember. So there's something really strange going on here, which is that our memories don't seem to follow our volition, our intention. They seem to have almost a mind of their own in some ways. What is it about the nature of the brain, Dan, that makes our intentions to remember something
在真正记住它时并不重要？这当然是推测，但从进化的角度来看，大脑这样设置似乎是有一定道理的，因为我们当下的判断可能并不准确。所以你的记忆系统以一种不同的方式下注。它存储的并不是你认为应该存储的东西。
not matter very much when it comes to actually remembering it? This is speculation, of course, but it seems to make a certain amount of evolutionary sense that this would not be a great way to set up a brain because our judgment in the moment may not be very good. So your memory system sort of lays its bets in a different way. It doesn't store what it is that you think ought to be stored.
相反，无论你思考什么，那很可能就是你以后需要再次思考的东西。因此，这增加了它最终进入记忆系统的概率。所以从进化的角度来看，你提出的论点是，如果某件事占据了我们的思想，那么在某种
And instead, whatever it is you think about a whole lot, it's probably something you're going to have to think about again. And so that increases the probability that it's going to end up in the memory system. So from an evolutionary point of view, the argument you're making here is that if something is occupying our mind, then it's, in some
程度上，推断那件事一定很重要是合理且合乎逻辑的，因此在某种程度上，将记忆资源用于真正保存我们正在思考的事情是有意义的。正是如此。当我们说“占据你的思想”时，我们需要精确定义它的含义，
ways, reasonable and logical to infer that that thing must be important, and therefore it makes sense in some ways to devote the resources of memory to actually preserving the thing that we're thinking about. That's exactly it. And there are, when we say occupy your mind, we need to be precise about what that would mean
因为你的思想被占据的方式有很多种。你可以长时间思考某件事，但思考的方式非常肤浅、机械，这对记忆并没有什么好处。或者你可以简短地思考某件事，但思考得非常深入，你会思考它的含义，将其与你已知的其他事物联系起来，这对记忆非常有好处。现在，我们对记忆的第二个假设是，对材料产生一种愉悦的熟悉感将使我们以后能够记住它。我觉得这种情况也经常发生。
because there are different ways your mind can be occupied. You can be thinking about something for a long period of time, but thinking about it in a pretty shallow sort of robotic way, and that's not going to be very good for memory. Or you can think about something briefly, but in a really deep way where you're thinking about what it means, you're connecting it to other things that you know, and that's going to be really good for memory. Now a second assumption that we make about memory is that developing a pleasing sense of familiarity with the material will allow us to remember it later. So I feel like this happens all the time as well.
你必须发表一场演讲，你把稿子读了20遍，直到你觉得有把握背下来。你说这种自信在记忆方面可能是一个隐形敌人。为什么会这样，丹？是的，因为那种自信来自于熟悉感，而熟悉感并不是你通常想要的那种记忆。所以熟悉感是一种“我以前遇到过这个”的感觉，
You have to give a speech and you read over your script 20 times until you feel confident you have it. You say this confidence may be a secret enemy when it comes to memory. Why is that, Dan? Yeah, because that confidence is coming from familiarity and familiarity is not exactly the same type of memory that you usually want. So familiarity is the sense that I have encountered exactly the same type of memory that you usually want.
你可以非常迅速地做出这种判断。其他相关信息通常检索得较慢，需要多一点努力。例如，你可能在街上看到某人，心想，哦，他们看起来很眼熟。然后你却想不起来他们是谁。于是你开始尝试思考，我是从工作中认识他们的吗？他们去我常去的那家店吗？
So familiarity is the sense that I have encountered this before, and you can make that judgment very rapidly. Other connected information is usually retrieved more slowly, and will take a little bit more effort. So for example, you may see someone on the street and think, oh, they look familiar. And then you can't quite place them. So you start trying to think, do I know them from work? Do they go to a shop that I go to?
你本质上是在生成记忆线索，试图帮助自己获取更多关于此人是谁的信息并定位他们。所以我们习惯了这种想法，即通常会有一种非常快速的熟悉感，然后里面可能还有更多信息，但我们需要挖掘它。这就是熟悉感可能让你误入歧途的地方。我们习惯了熟悉感之后通常会伴随着其他信息，如果我们投入一点
And what you're essentially doing is generating memory cues to try to help you get more information about who this person is and place them. So we're used to this idea that there is often this very quick sense of familiarity and then there may be more information in there, but we're going to have to dig for it. So this is where familiarity can lead you astray. We're used to the idea that familiarity is often followed by other information if we put in a little
更多的努力。但也可能根本没有其他信息。所以当你准备那场演讲时，你所做的只是通过一遍又一遍地阅读，给了自己一种非常强烈的熟悉感，但你实际上并不能记住演讲内容，而这正是你以后需要做到的。除了读20遍演讲稿并确信我们已经背下来之外，还有什么替代策略？参与你当时真正需要的心理过程。所以你想要
bit more effort. It could be there is no other information. And so as you're preparing for that speech, all you've done is by reading it over and over and over again, is give yourself a very strong sense of familiarity, but you're not actually able to remember the speech, which is what you're going to need to be able to do later. What is the alternative strategy to reading a speech 20 times and feeling confident that we have memorized it? Engage the mental processes that you're actually going to need at the time. So what you're going to want to
做的是能够只偶尔参考笔记就完成演讲。所以你需要练习只偶尔参考笔记来发表演讲。当然，这样做的问题是，它会更难，而且
do is to be able to give the speech with only occasional reference to your notes. So you need to practice giving the speech with only occasional reference to your notes. The thing about that, of course, is that's going to be harder and it's
你会感觉自己失败的频率更高。但这正是你真正需要做的。这会更难，而且你会感觉自己失败的频率更高，但这正是你真正需要做的，也是对记忆最好的方式。你知道，我在想，当我们试图学习某样东西时，通常当我们回顾教科书中的材料时，我们会说，是的，我很熟悉它，看起来很对，我知道那是什么。在某种程度上，我们是在安慰自己，我们掌握了这些材料。我想我听到你说的是，一个更好的策略，尽管可能更令人不快，
going to feel like you're failing a lot more frequently. But this is what you actually need to do. And this is that's what's going to be harder and it's going to feel like you're failing a lot more frequently, but this is what you actually need to do and this is that's what's going to be best for memory. You know I'm thinking that when we are trying to learn something very often when we you know look back at the material in a textbook for example and we say yeah I'm familiar with it that that looks that looks right I know what that is. Partly what we're doing is we're reassuring ourselves that we know the material. And I think what I'm hearing you say is that a better strategy, though perhaps more unpleasant,
是真正去挖掘我们知识中真正缺乏的具体地方。所以，与其试图向自己证明我们掌握了材料，不如真正向自己证明我们在哪里不了解材料，我们的弱点可以告诉我们应该关注哪里。我认为这完全正确。你需要测试自己，看看你知道什么，不知道什么，然后针对你不知道的部分进行练习。当你这样解释时，这听起来非常明显，但即使
is to actually try and unearth the specific places in our knowledge where we are actually lacking. So rather than trying to show us, prove to ourselves that we know the material, to actually prove to ourselves where we don't know the material, our weaknesses, can tell us where to focus. I think that's exactly right. You need to test yourself, see what you know and what you don't know, and then work on the part that you don't know. It sounds very obvious when you've explicated it the way you have, but even though
当你这么说时听起来很明显，大多数人还是不会这样做。我记得多年前在安吉拉·达克沃斯写完关于“坚毅”的书后与她交谈。她的研究之一是观察拼字比赛冠军。她发现拼字比赛冠军显然投入了大量时间准备，但他们也进行了她所说的“刻意练习”。她定义刻意练习的方式与你所说的非常相似，丹，即这是一个刻意尝试识别弱点领域的过程，
it sounds obvious when you say it, it's something that most people don't do. I remember talking to Angela Duckworth many years ago after she wrote her book on grit. And one of her studies was looking at spelling bee champions. And the thing that she found was that spelling bee champions, you know, obviously put in a lot of time in preparation, but they also did what she called deliberate practice. And the way she defined deliberate practice was very similar to what you're talking about, Dan, which is it was a process of deliberately trying to identify areas of weakness
并专注于这些弱点领域。当然，这一定是非常令人不快和困难的。绝对是这样，这也是定义具有坚毅品质的人的特征之一，他们能够面对这些困难的任务，一次专注于一件事，并说，好吧，这段音乐的这一特定段落，我正在尝试学习，这是我真正感到困难的地方。
and focus on those areas of weakness. And of course, that has to be very unpleasant and difficult to do. Absolutely, and this is one of the things that define people with grit, is that they're able to face up to these sorts of difficult tasks and focus on one thing at a time and say, okay, this particular passage of this piece of music, I'm trying to learn this is what I'm really having difficulty with.
此外，刻意练习的另一个非常重要的方面是思考克服这种困难的策略，准备好发挥创造力，尝试不同的方法，并进行实验，看看如何克服这个问题。我们对记忆的第三个假设是，一旦我们知道某件事，我们就知道了，我们的工作就完成了。但当然，知道某件事并不能保护我们免受这样一个事实的影响：有一个沉默的过程
And in addition, the other aspect of deliberate practice that's really important is thinking of strategies to overcome this difficulty, being ready to be creative and try different things and experiment to see how you can overcome the problem. A third assumption we make about memory is that once we know something, we know it, that our work is done. But of course, knowing something doesn't protect us from the fact that there is a silent process
会一点点侵蚀我们所知道的东西。你能谈谈这个吗？我们想象我们知道某些事情，但我们经常低估自己忘记它们的能力。这是记忆的一个非常奇特的方面。我们想象我们现在的记忆状态在未来也会持续下去。所以我们完全忽略了遗忘。奇怪的是，我们也会做同样的事情，
that can chip away at what we know. Can you talk about this, that we imagine we know things, but we often underestimate our capacity to forget them? This is a really peculiar aspect of memory. And we imagine that the state of our memory now will continue to be the state of our memory in the future. So we completely discount forgetting. And curiously, we do the same thing,
即使当我们计划学习更多内容时。在实验中，他们会让人进来，让他们学习一些东西，而且是人们完全不熟悉的东西。比如英语到斯瓦希里语的词汇翻译之类的。他们会说，好吧，你已经学习了这20个单词，你大约答对了80%。
even when we plan on studying more. So in the experiments, what they'll do is they'll bring people in, they'll have them learn something, and it's something that people have no familiarity with at all. It'll be like English to Swahili translation of vocabulary or something. And they'll say, okay, well, you've studied these 20 words, you're getting about 80 percent correct.
我希望你回家，两周后再回来。我们将再次做同样的事情。顺便问一下，你觉得你第一次回来时会表现如何？人们说，嗯，我答对了80%。我想我可能还会答对80%。他们完全忽略了在这两周内会发生遗忘。根据我与学生的经验，一旦你指出并解释了这一点，他们理解起来并不困难。
I want you to go home, come back in two weeks. We're going to do the same thing again. By the way, how do you think you'll do when you come back for the first time? And people say, well, I'm getting 80%. I guess I'll probably get 80% again. They just completely discount that forgetting will happen in those two weeks. And in my experience with my students, once you point this out and explain it, it's not difficult for them to understand.
但如果你不指出，人们根本不会去想它。所以你说，对抗这种不可避免的遗忘过程的一种方法不仅是学习，还要对我们试图记住的材料进行“过度学习”。这看起来是什么样的，丹？过度学习意味着继续复习和练习你想要学习的某些内容，即使在你看来你已经掌握得非常好了。假设你正在使用抽认卡或类似的东西进行英语到斯瓦希里语的翻译，并且你每次运行抽认卡列表时都答对了，你简直太棒了。过度学习说，继续下去。你可以想象，当你这样做时，
But people just don't think about it if you don't point it out. So you say that one way to counteract this inevitable process of forgetting is not just to learn, but to overlearn the material we're trying to remember. What does this look like, Dan? Overlearning means continuing to rehearse and practice some content that you want to learn, even when it seems to you, you know it perfectly well. So suppose you're, you know, working with flashcards or something with our English Sweeley translation, and you're getting them right every time you're running through the list of flashcards, you're just killing it. Overlearning says, keep going. And you can imagine that as you're doing that,
你会想，这有什么意义？我全都答对了，我知道了。但你在过度学习的过程中所做的是，你在防止遗忘。所以你花了很多年研究记忆是如何运作的，以及如何修复记忆缺失。然后你说，好吧，让我出去教我的学生如何更好地学习，如何成为更好的学生。
you would think, what is the point of this? I'm getting them all right, I know it. But what you're doing in this process of overlearning is you're protecting against forgetting. So you spend many years studying how memory works and studying how to fix lapses in memory. And then you say, okay, let me go out and teach my students how to learn better, how to be better students.
当然，你是一名教育工作者，所以这是一个完美的场景，因为学生们想要学习并记住他们所学的东西。告诉我你向学生传授这些想法的努力。他们掌握了你的见解并开始更好地记住事情了吗？结果真的不像我想象的那样。
And of course, you're an educator, so it's the perfect setting because students want to learn and remember the things that they have learned. Tell me about your efforts to teach these ideas to your students. Did they master your insights and start to remember things better? It really didn't work out the way I thought it was going to work out.
我首先与那些来找我的学生交谈，因为他们对自己在我的课程中的进步不满意。我问了他们很多详细的问题，比如，你现在在做什么？把你的笔记拿来，让我们看看，等等。所以我感觉我在诊断每个学生的具体情况方面变得相当不错。我给出了这些建议，他们点着头，看起来好像都听进去了。
I started by talking to the students who were coming to see me because they were unhappy with their progress in my course. And I asked them a lot of detailed questions about, well, what are you doing now? And like, bring in your notes and let's look at them, so on. And so I felt like I was getting pretty good at diagnosing what was going on with each individual student. And I was dispensing this advice and they were nodding and looking like they were taking it all in.
但我监控了他们的成绩，发现他们并没有进步。所以我对此感到非常困惑。大约一年后，我开始跟进这些学生，说，我们谈过话，告诉我，你做了我建议你做的事吗？我发现一个非常普遍的回答是，我试过了，但感觉很蠢。感觉一点效果都没有。所以我停止了。所以从某种程度上说，有效的事情感觉并不有效，因此凭直觉，人们不会坚持下去。完全正确。这与我发现的另一个现象有关，
And I monitored their grades and I found that they were not improving. So I was very puzzled by this. So after about a year of that, I started following up with those students and saying, so we had this conversation, tell me, you know, did you do what what I suggested you do? And I found a very common response was, I tried it and it just felt stupid. It just didn't feel like it was effective at all. And so I stopped doing it. So in some ways the things that were effective don't feel like they're effective and so intuitively people don't stick to it. That's exactly right. It's connected to another phenomenon that I discovered and
我非常感兴趣，那就是学生在K-12阶段并没有被教导他们应该如何学习、如何记笔记，以及他们在学校里需要做的所有不同事情。他们当然没有被教导记忆是如何运作的。然而，他们似乎都使用相同的记忆策略。原因在于他们都倾向于那些
was very interested in which is that students are not taught in K through 12 how they should study, how to take notes, all the different things they're gonna need to do in school. And they're certainly not taught about how their memory works. And yet they all seem to use the same strategies for memorization. And the reason is they all gravitate towards strategies
在当下感觉有效且不那么困难的策略。那些能增强我们记忆的策略感觉并不令人满意或富有成效。所以我们抛弃了它们，转而选择那些感觉正确但往往效果较差甚至适得其反的策略。就像弹簧恢复原状一样，我们回到了我们简单的直觉假设，尽管这些假设往往是错误的。回来后，我们将探讨如何赢得与自己的战斗，并开始实践科学揭示的那些硬道理，
that feel effective in the moment and that also aren't that difficult. The strategies that work to strengthen our memory don't feel satisfying or productive. So we discard them in favor of strategies that feel right but are often less effective or even counterproductive. Like a spring reverting to its old shape, we revert to our easy intuitive assumptions even though those assumptions are often wrong. When we come back, how to win the battle with ourselves and start to practice the hard truths uncovered by science that
这些道理实际上能让我们的记忆更强大。这些道理实际上能让我们的记忆更强大。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。丹·威林厄姆是弗吉尼亚大学的认知科学家。他研究记忆是如何运作的以及它是如何失败的。丹·威林厄姆是弗吉尼亚大学的认知科学家。他研究记忆是如何运作的以及它是如何失败的。丹也是这本书的作者，
actually make our memory stronger. that actually make our memories stronger. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Dan Willingham is a cognitive scientist at the University of Virginia. He studies how memory works and how it fails. Dan Willingham is a cognitive scientist at the University of Virginia. He studies how memory works and how it fails. Dan is also the author of the book,
《智胜你的大脑：为什么学习很难，以及你如何让它变得容易》。丹，我们已经看到了科学是如何提出增强记忆的见解的。问题在于，我们大多数人并不使用这些见解，因为它们感觉并不令人满意或容易。你用体育锻炼做类比，帮助人们理解你关于创造持久记忆所需的努力程度的观点。做俯卧撑和
Outsmart Your Brain, Why Learning Is Hard, and How You Can Make It Easy. Dan, we've seen how science has come up with insights into strengthening memory. The problem is that most of us don't use these insights because they don't feel satisfying or easy. You draw an analogy with physical exercise to help people understand your point about the kind of effort that's necessary to create lasting memories. What's the connection between doing push-ups and
拥有更好的记忆力之间有什么联系？是的，想象一下你有一个朋友正在努力增强力量，他们想能够做很多很多俯卧撑。所以你去看望他们一次，看到他们在训练，发现他们在膝盖着地做俯卧撑。你说，你为什么要这样做？如果你想做很多常规俯卧撑，你应该做常规俯卧撑。事实上，与其做常规俯卧撑，你应该做非常困难的俯卧撑，比如
having a better memory? Yeah, so imagine that you've got a friend who is trying to gain strength and they want to be able to do lots and lots of push-ups. So you go and visit them one time and see them training and you find them doing push-ups on their knees. And you say, why in the world do you like if you want to do a lot of regular push-ups, you should do regular push-ups. In fact, instead of regular push-ups, you should do really difficult push-ups like the
那种你把自己从地板上弹起来并拍手的俯卧撑。你的朋友说，是的，有几个人告诉过我，我也试过了，但我几乎做不了几个那样的俯卧撑。这里的重点是我在尝试做很多俯卧撑，对吧？但你看，当我膝盖着地做俯卧撑时，我可以很快做很多。所以这有点像同一件事。很多时候，当人们试图记住事情时，他们是在做心理上的“膝盖着地俯卧撑”。他们做的事情在当下感觉有效，而且感觉容易。但当然你需要挑战。而且当然它必须是正确类型的挑战。它不能只是
ones where you launch yourself off the floor and clap. And your friend says, yeah, a couple of people have told me that and I tried it, but like I could hardly do any of those push-ups. And the whole point here is I'm trying to do a lot of push-ups, right? But look, when I do push-ups on my knees, I can do so many so quickly. So it's sort of the same thing. A lot of times when people are trying to commit things to memory, they're doing the mental equivalent of push-ups on their knees. They're doing things that feel effective in the moment and also feel easy. But of course you need the challenge. And of course it has to be the right type of challenge. It can't just
任何挑战，但正确类型的挑战会从长远来看给你带来好处。所以让我们听听一些心理上的“俯卧撑”，那种能让你从地板上弹起足够长的时间来拍手的练习。你已经解释过，我们对一条信息的记忆与我们围绕该信息进行的心理活动有关。这个见解的含义是什么
be any challenge, but the right type of challenge is going to bring you the benefit in the long run. So let's hear about some of the mental equivalents of doing pushups that propel you off the floor long enough to clap. You've explained that our memory for a piece of information is related to the mental activities we engage in around that information. What is the implication of this insight
在制定记忆保留策略方面？所以你能做的最好的事情之一就是组织你试图学习的信息。记忆喜欢意义。当事物对我们有意义时，这意味着你试图学习的所有零碎信息都相互关联，这样当你记住其中一部分时，那将有助于挖掘出
in terms of devising a memory retention strategy? So one of the best things you can do is organize the information that you're trying to learn. Memory loves meaning. When things are meaningful to us, that means that all the bits and pieces of what you're trying to learn are connected to one another so that when you remember part of it, that's going to help dredge up the
其余的部分。此外，将其与你已经了解的事物联系起来。这也是有帮助的，将其整合到更广泛的记忆网络中会非常有帮助。所以思考为什么某件事是真的，而不仅仅是，你知道，好吧，我有这个事实，那个事实，那个事实，尝试找到一种方法来组织它们，将它们相互联系起来。而且很多时候，我刚才给出的那个建议有点难遵循。
rest of it. And then also connecting it to things that you already know something about. That's also helpful, sort of integrating it into sort of the broader memory web is going to be really helpful. So thinking about why something is true, not just, you know, okay, I've got this fact and this fact and this fact, trying to find a way to organize them to connect them to one another. And then a lot of times that that advice I've just given is a little bit hard to follow.
它有点模糊。就像“思考意义”，你的大脑并没有被设置为仅仅遵循那样的命令。如果你给自己一个具体的任务，它会工作得更好。所以问自己为什么某件事是真的，或者如何做某事，这更有可能引导你走上思考它意味着什么的道路。没错，在某种程度上，这与这样一个想法有关：如果我只是在读教科书，那可能不如阅读教科书、思考它，然后
It's a little vague. It's like think about meaning your brain is not set up to just sort of follow a command like that. It works much better if you give yourself a concrete task. So asking yourself why something is true or how to do something, that's more likely to sort of lead you down this path about thinking about what it means. Right, and in some ways this is connected to the idea that if I'm just reading a textbook, that might not be as effective as reading the textbook, thinking about it, and then
真正写一个围绕该章节课程的练习有效，因为它实际上现在促使我说，我如何自己联系这些想法？我是否对整个想法、该章节中想法的含义有一个连贯的画面？这完全正确，我将从两个方面详细说明你刚才所说的。一是当你提到阅读时思考意义，我们都有过这样的阅读经历，基本上在这种情况下，我们的眼睛只是扫过材料，当你读到页面底部时，你意识到我一直在想午餐。我根本没有在思考这些内容。所以即使是那种情况的较轻版本也可能发生，即是的，你在思考它，但并没有那么深入。所以另一件事是，这非常普遍，有
actually having to write an exercise that is built around the lessons in that section, because it's actually causing me now to say, how can I connect the ideas myself? And do I have sort of a cohesive picture of the whole idea, the meaning of the idea, that's in that section. That's absolutely right and I'll elaborate on what you just said in two ways. One is when you said thinking about meaning while you're reading, we've all had the experience of reading which basically in this case is sort of our eyes drifting over the material and you get to the bottom of a page and you realize I've been thinking about lunch. I've not been thinking about this content at all. And so even a softer version of that can happen where yeah, you're sort of thinking about it, but not all that deeply. So the other thing is, and this is very common, there are
很多研究表明，人们在阅读时，他们逐句理解，但他们没有做很多事情，那就是协调句子之间的意义和段落之间的意义。好吧，那么这段话在考虑到我刚读完的内容时意味着什么？你刚才建议的那种小小的心理练习，比如让我思考这意味着什么，让我看看我是否能创建一个总结
lots of studies showing this, that one of the things that people do is they're reading and they're understanding sentence by sentence, but what they're not doing a lot of is coordinating meaning across sentences and coordinating meaning across paragraphs. Okay, so what does this paragraph mean in light of what I just finished reading? And the little sort of mental exercise you just suggested, like let me think about what this means, let me see if I can create a summary of this
这一节，让我看看我正在读的这本书的副标题，看看作者为什么选择那个副标题。这就是那种会鼓励你进行句子和段落之间意义协调的事情。这对记忆非常有好处。你指出，许多出于好意的课堂练习实际上并没有引导学生以一种创造持久记忆的方式思考材料。
section, let me look at the subheading for this book that I'm reading and see why the author chose that subheading. That's the kind of thing that's going to encourage you to do this coordination of meaning across sentences and paragraphs. That's going to be great for memory. You've pointed out that many well-intentioned classroom exercises don't actually lead students to think about the material in a way that creates lasting memories.
你能告诉我们你听说的那个老师吗？他试图让他的学生了解19世纪将奴隶带向自由的秘密网络。是的，我实际上观察了这节课。这是给小学中年级学生，大概四年级，关于地下铁路的课程，老师试图向他们强调的一个重点是，这些试图逃跑的人所面临的不确定性，不仅是在被追捕和危险方面，而且
Can you tell us about the teacher you heard about who was trying to get his students to learn about the secret network that carried enslaved people to freedom in the 19th century? Yeah, this was actually I observed this lesson. So the this was a lesson for middle elementary students, probably fourth grade, on the Underground Railroad and one of the things that teacher was trying to emphasize to them was the uncertainty for these people trying to make their escape, not only in terms of being pursued and the danger of it, but also
比如你从哪里弄到食物，你将如何旅行等等。所以老师所做的是让他们烤饼干，因为这显然是一种主食。学生们可能花了大约30秒思考饼干与内容之间的关系，这与地下铁路有什么关系。他们可能花了大约20或30分钟思考测量面粉、切起酥油等等。对吧？所以我告诉老师们，听着，学生们记不住他们想要记住的东西。
like where are you going to get food and how are you going to travel and so on. And so what the teacher did was actually have them bake biscuits because this was apparently a mainstay food. And the students probably spent about 30 seconds thinking about the relationship between biscuits and the content, what this had to do with the Underground Railroad. And they probably spent about 20 or 30 minutes thinking about measuring flour, cutting shortening, and so on. Right? So what I tell teachers is, listen, students don't remember what they want to remember.
比如你要去哪里找食物，你要怎么旅行等等。所以老师实际上让他们烤饼干，因为这显然是当时的主食。学生们可能只花了大约30秒思考饼干与教学内容之间的关系，以及这与地下铁路有什么关系。而他们可能花了20到30分钟在测量面粉、切起酥油等等上，对吧？所以我告诉老师们，听着，学生们不会记住他们想要记住的东西。
They certainly don't remember what their teachers want them to remember. They remember what they think about. So if they're spending most of their time thinking about how to bake biscuits, that's what they're gonna get out of the lesson plan. How do you think the lesson plan should have been changed to get a better outcome?
他们当然记不住老师想让他们记住的东西。他们只会记住自己思考过的内容。所以，如果他们大部分时间都在想怎么烤饼干，那这就是他们从教案中学到的东西。你认为应该如何修改教案才能获得更好的效果？
I think in this case, if the goal was to get the students to think about the practical aspects of what it would be like to try and escape via the Underground Railroad, something where they encourage them to think about, okay, here are your resources, here are all of the dangers that are facing you. What do you suppose people did in these circumstances? How do you think they solve
我认为在这种情况下，如果目标是让学生思考通过“地下铁路”逃亡的实际情况，那么应该鼓励他们思考：好吧，你现在拥有这些资源，面临着这些危险。你认为人们在这些情况下会怎么做？你认为他们是如何解决
this problem? That would be a way to get them to think about the aspect of the content that I think was meant to be the focus. You talk about another technique called elaborative interrogation. What is this, Dan, and how does it work? This is a technique to improve comprehension and also improve memory, where as you're reading something, you pose questions to yourself and try to answer the questions. It's even more effective if before you start reading the text, you actually look ahead a little bit and make some predictions about what you think you're likely to learn when you read this text and then pose questions based on that little
这个问题的？这会是一种让他们思考内容核心的方式，而我认为这才是重点。你提到了另一种技巧，叫“阐述性提问”。丹，这是什么？它是如何运作的？这是一种提高理解力和记忆力的方法，即在你阅读时，向自己提出问题并尝试回答。如果你在开始阅读文本之前，先稍微浏览一下，对你认为可能会学到的内容做一些预测，然后基于这些预览提出问题，效果会更好。
preview that you do. And then when you're reading the text, you're thinking about did I pose good questions? Is this actually what the text is about? And if it is, what are the answers to those questions? And if it's not, what are some better questions? I mean, and all of this in some ways goes back to that idea we talked about, which is that we remember what it is we're mentally engaged with.
然后当你阅读文本时，你会思考：我提出的问题好吗？这真的是文本的主旨吗？如果是，这些问题的答案是什么？如果不是，有什么更好的问题吗？我的意思是，这一切在某种程度上又回到了我们讨论过的那个观点，即我们只会记住我们精神上投入过的内容。
And so if you want to remember things, you have to find ways to actually engage with the material, not just simply be a passive recipient for it, but actually think about it, engage it, probe it, try and see the connections between that and other ideas, contest it, argue with it. That's the way you actually remember the material, not just simply listening to it. That's absolutely right. And these little tricks I think help because again, one of the things that it's hard to do is sort of tell yourself, okay, now I'm really going to think deeply about this. You need something more concrete.
所以，如果你想记住某些东西，你必须找到真正参与到材料中的方法，而不仅仅是被动地接收，而是要思考它、钻研它、探究它，尝试找出它与其他观点之间的联系，质疑它、反驳它。这才是你真正记住材料的方法，而不仅仅是听听而已。完全正确。我认为这些小技巧很有帮助，因为正如我所说，很难做到告诉自己“好吧，现在我要深入思考这个问题了”。你需要更具体的东西。
So the technique like, well, you know, look at the subheadings and try and generate some questions based on that. That gives the mind something to work with where you see what the path forward is instead of just telling people, well, really think about what it means. Another way of harnessing meaning is to frame the information that you're processing in the form of a story. Tell me about this idea, Dan. Yes, stories are very effective because stories have connections, stories have causality in them, right?
所以像“看看小标题并尝试据此提出一些问题”这样的技巧，能给大脑提供一些可以处理的东西，让你看到前进的方向，而不是仅仅告诉人们“好好想想这意味着什么”。利用意义的另一种方法是将你正在处理的信息组织成故事的形式。跟我说说这个想法，丹。是的，故事非常有效，因为故事有联系，故事里有因果关系，对吧？
It's in the nature of stories that event B was caused by event A. And so you can think about when there's content that you would like to master, thinking of whether or not it fits well into a story context can be a really effective way of organizing it. And I understand there's been research that has tested
故事的本质就是事件B是由事件A引起的。因此，当你想要掌握某些内容时，思考它是否适合放入故事背景中，可以成为组织这些内容的一种非常有效的方法。我了解到有一些研究测试过
when people get information just as information and when people get information in the form of a story, there are differences in how well people remember the information? Yeah, absolutely. It's very clever experiments where they took basically the same set of facts that they were hoping to impart to the people who are going to be reading it. And some people read what you would just think of as a straightforward expository essay that laid out the facts.
当人们仅仅作为信息获取信息，以及当人们以故事形式获取信息时，人们对信息的记忆程度是否存在差异？是的，绝对有。这是一些非常巧妙的实验，他们基本上采用了同一组事实，希望传达给阅读的人。有些人读的是你认为的那种直截了当的说明性文章，陈述了事实。
And then other people had the same facts sort of shaped into a story format. Again, the emphasis within the story was on causality connections among these various pieces. And what they found was that people who read it in story format remembered the information better. And in some ways, I think this speaks to the idea that what you're talking about is really not just discrete pieces of information, but the architecture of how all this information fits together. And of course in a well-constructed story, you don't just have a whole bunch of discrete pieces of information, you actually have the entire architecture of the Lego building, if you will, with all the pieces sort of
而另一些人读的是将同样的事实塑造成故事格式的内容。同样，故事的重点在于这些不同部分之间的因果联系。他们发现，阅读故事格式的人能更好地记住这些信息。在某种程度上，我认为这说明了你所谈论的不仅仅是零散的信息，而是所有这些信息如何组合在一起的架构。当然，在一个结构良好的故事中，你不仅仅有一堆零散的信息，你实际上拥有了整个乐高建筑的架构，如果可以这样比喻的话，所有的零件都以某种方式
connected to one another. So to identify, when you're asked to identify any individual piece, you have a sense of where it sits in the in the overall scheme Absolutely. I mean the connections are are so important And I mean some everyday evidence about this think about the last time someone you went to a movie and the next day someone asked You oh you saw that movie. What was that about? No one ever says oh, I don know, like I didn't study it. You know, I just saw it. I can't remember it. No, the memory just comes for free when you're engaged with a story. And it is, as you say, it's all these Lego pieces fitting
相互连接。所以当你被要求识别任何单个零件时，你会感觉到它在整体方案中的位置。绝对是这样。我的意思是，这些联系非常重要。想想看，你上次去看电影，第二天有人问你：“哦，你看了那部电影。讲的是什么？”从来没有人会说：“哦，我不知道，我没研究过。我只是看了看。我记不住了。”不，当你沉浸在故事中时，记忆是自然而然产生的。正如你所说，这就是所有乐高积木拼装
together because that's so intrinsic to the way memory works. You remember things based on cues. You get a hint. I say this and then I say salt. You remember things based on cues. You get a hint, I say this, and then I say salt, that makes you think of pepper. These two things are connected in memory. So in a story, everything is connected to something else. So it's sort of like at the beginning of the story, it's like you're pulling out this very fine chain
在一起，因为这对于记忆的工作方式来说是内在的。你是基于线索来记忆事物的。你得到一个提示。我说这个，然后我说“盐”。你基于线索记忆事物。你得到一个提示，我说这个，然后我说“盐”，这会让你想到“胡椒”。这两件事在记忆中是相连的。所以在一个故事中，一切都与别的东西相连。所以这就像在故事的开头，你拉出这条非常细的链子
and the little pieces of the story are like little like you're pulling out this very fine chain and the little pieces of the story are like little charms attached to the chain. You just keep tugging and it keeps coming out and it's easy to remember. You and others have talked about different elements in stories that are worth thinking about. If we wanted to construct stories to remember things, what are these elements that we should focus on, Dan? Conflict is the way it's usually described in story structure.
而故事的小片段就像挂在链子上的小饰品。你只要不断地拉，它就会不断地出来，而且很容易记住。你和其他人谈论过故事中值得思考的不同元素。如果我们想构建故事来记住事物，我们应该关注哪些元素，丹？冲突通常是故事结构中的描述方式。
So in Star Wars, you know, is Luke going to be able to save the civilization by destroying the Death Star? He needs something to fight against, so it's going to be Darth Vader. With our combined strength, we can end this destructive conflict and bring order to the galaxy. I'll never join you! And then there, again, when you're thinking about story structure, you're usually thinking about multiple pieces. So the other aspect in addition to conflict is complication. So the first try at the solution to the problem
所以在《星球大战》中，你知道，卢克能通过摧毁死星来拯救文明吗？他需要对抗的东西，所以那将是达斯·维达。“凭借我们的联合力量，我们可以结束这场破坏性的冲突，为银河系带来秩序。”“我永远不会加入你！”然后，当你思考故事结构时，你通常会考虑多个部分。所以除了冲突之外，另一个方面是复杂化。所以你解决问题的第一次尝试
that you've figured out usually doesn't work for one reason or another. That's a complication. Then there's a sub problem that you have to figure out. And again, that makes for very nice connections that helps you sort of keep it all organized in your mind and easier to remember. Can you also talk about the role that characters play
通常因为某种原因行不通。这就是复杂化。然后有一个你需要解决的子问题。同样，这创造了非常好的联系，帮助你把一切组织在脑海中，更容易记住。你还能谈谈角色所扮演的角色吗？
in our memories, the characters that we encounter in stories would seem to be an important component of what makes stories memorable. Absolutely, and again, you know, if there are people in what you're trying to remember, that's going to be really helpful. Individual personalities help, distinctiveness helps memory.
在我们的记忆中，我们在故事中遇到的角色似乎是让故事令人难忘的重要组成部分。绝对是这样，而且同样，你知道，如果你试图记住的内容中有人物，那会非常有帮助。个人性格有帮助，独特性有助于记忆。
Things that stand out because they're unlike other things that you've encountered, that's a very general principle of memory, that things that are really distinctive are much easier to remember. So if you've got individual people, then that's great. If you don't have individual people, you can still think of something analogous in your story
那些因为与你遇到的其他事物不同而脱颖而出的事物，这是一个非常普遍的记忆原则，即真正独特的事物更容易记住。所以如果你有具体的人，那就太好了。如果你没有具体的人，你仍然可以在你的故事中想到类似的东西
where sort of the action is. I was describing this to a physicist and he immediately said, energy. In any physical system, I always look for the energy because that's where the action is gonna be. And I don't know enough physics to really evaluate whether or not that was right, but his eyes lit up when he was telling me that. So that's a way of thinking about the role of character, not just in stories where there are actually people, but in other types of stories as well.
动作发生的地方。我曾向一位物理学家描述过这一点，他立刻说：“能量”。在任何物理系统中，我总是寻找能量，因为那是动作发生的地方。我没有足够的物理知识来评估这是否正确，但他告诉我这些时，眼睛闪闪发光。所以这是一种思考角色作用的方式，不仅是在有真人的故事中，在其他类型的故事中也是如此。
And I'm thinking about plays or movies, you know, a movie like Beautiful Mind, I think, did far more to popularize the ideas of John Nash, the mathematician, than any number of mathematics textbooks. And Hamilton, the play, probably did more for, you know, U.S. history and American history and people, students understanding American history, than, you know, countless history classes. After the war, I went back to New York. Yes, those were beautiful examples of character-driven stories. So sometimes, Dan, the information we have to memorize
我想到戏剧或电影，你知道，像《美丽心灵》这样的电影，我认为它在普及数学家约翰·纳什的思想方面所做的贡献，远超任何数量的数学教科书。而戏剧《汉密尔顿》，可能在让美国历史和人们、学生理解美国历史方面，比无数的历史课做得更多。“战后，我回到了纽约。”是的，这些都是以角色为驱动的故事的绝佳例子。所以有时，丹，我们必须记住的信息
is not in itself very meaningful. So let's say you're trying to remember the names of all the presidents of the United States. There's obviously no meaning to the names. There's no story to connect all the names together. What do we do? The go-to method here is a mnemonic. And the mnemonics are ways of lending meaning to something
本身并不是很有意义。所以假设你试图记住所有美国总统的名字。这些名字显然没有意义。没有故事可以将所有名字联系在一起。我们该怎么办？这里的首选方法是助记符。助记符是赋予某事物意义的方法
that doesn't have any meaning, or other times it's another sort of a trick that helps the information become easier to pull out of memory. Have you done this? Are there mnemonics that you still remember from your childhood? Absolutely. And in junior year of high school, my teacher asked all of us to
那些没有任何意义的东西，或者有时它是另一种有助于信息更容易从记忆中提取出来的技巧。你做过这个吗？有没有你童年时期至今仍记得的助记符？绝对有。在高三那年，我的老师要求我们所有人
memorize the US presidents in order and taught us a little mnemonic song to commit them to memory. I'm going to put you on the spot here, Dan. Let's give it a go. Wajma JV hut-putt-fumple JG-HG AC-HC, A.C. Hasey, McRu, Tawu, Haku, Huru, Trimacan, John X. Ford, Carrigan, Bush. And what does that stand for? I'm sort of starting to pick up the outlines of the names there. Yeah. So it's the first letter of each president's name.
按顺序背诵美国总统，并教了我们一首小小的助记歌来记住他们。我要让你当场表演一下，丹。我们试试看。Wajma JV hut-putt-fumple JG-HG AC-HC, A.C. Hasey, McRu, Tawu, Haku, Huru, Trimacan, John X. Ford, Carrigan, Bush。那代表什么？我开始看出那些名字的轮廓了。是的。所以这是每位总统名字的首字母。
So it starts, Wah Jemah. So Wah is Washington Adams, Jemah Jefferson, Madison Monroe, Adams, JV Jackson Van Buren. And then occasionally you have to remember some things. So like Trumaken is Truman and then Ike for Eisenhower. And then it ends Ken for Kennedy. So there are little bits in there. We have to do some interpretation, but of course that's not hard. And I will say I probably recite that little rhyme to myself once or twice a year when for some reason I'm trying to think now who is probably president at that point. Needless to say, you have to be kind of quiet when you do it. Socially it's a little awkward. So we've talked about how easy it is for us to feel a sense of familiarity with a given set of facts, but instead of familiarity, you suggest that we need to adopt a new standard of what it means to know something, something that can overcome our illusion of explanatory depth, where we believe we know things better than we actually know them.
所以它开始是“Wah Jemah”。Wah是华盛顿、亚当斯，Jemah是杰斐逊、麦迪逊、门罗、亚当斯，JV是杰克逊、范布伦。然后偶尔你需要记住一些东西。比如Trumaken是杜鲁门，然后Ike是艾森豪威尔。然后以Ken结尾是肯尼迪。所以里面有一些小片段。我们必须做一些解释，但这当然不难。我得说，我可能一年会对自己背诵一两次那首小韵文，当出于某种原因我试图想“那时是谁当总统”时。不用说，你做的时候得安静点。在社交场合这有点尴尬。所以我们已经讨论过我们对一组给定的事实产生熟悉感是多么容易，但你建议我们采用一种关于“知道某事意味着什么”的新标准，这种标准可以克服我们对解释深度的错觉，即我们认为自己比实际知道得更多。
What is the technique that you suggest, Dan? things better than we actually know them. What is the technique that you suggest, Dan? Most of the time, the technique is going to be posing the question to yourself and seeing whether or not you can explain it. I would elaborate on this a little bit. I would say that the technique you use to test your memory should be a good fit for what you actually want to be able to do with the
你建议的技巧是什么，丹？我们认为自己比实际知道得更多。你建议的技巧是什么，丹？大多数时候，这个技巧就是向自己提出问题，看看你是否能解释它。我会对此稍作阐述。我会说，你用来测试记忆力的技巧应该非常适合你实际想要用这些
information. So for example, this happens comes up a lot in the context of mathematics. Students will learn a particular formula to solve a particular type of problem and they learn it in the context of a word problem that's to do with football players for example. And then on the test, the same principle is tested. They need to use the same formula. But now it's not football players. Now it's automobiles or something else. And they fail to recognize the information.
信息做什么。例如，这种情况在数学背景下经常出现。学生会学习一个特定的公式来解决特定类型的问题，他们是在与足球运动员相关的应用题背景下学习它的。然后在考试中，同样的原理被测试。他们需要使用同样的公式。但现在不是足球运动员了。现在是汽车或其他东西。他们没能识别出这些信息。
This is a different type of recognition. And it's actually much more difficult. So memory tends to cling to the examples that we initially encountered. So you need to think about, what am I actually wanting to do with this information? Do I need to be able to just describe it to others? That's what we talked about as being more difficult than just
这是一种不同类型的识别。而且实际上要困难得多。所以记忆倾向于依附于我们最初遇到的例子。所以你需要思考：我实际上想用这些信息做什么？我需要能够仅仅向别人描述它吗？这就是我们所说的比仅仅
recognizing it. Or do I need to be able to recognize it in new guises? That's still more difficult. So take the problem that was about football and take the problem that was about automobiles. Take those two problems that look different on the surface and then describe how are these actually similar? And Shankar, this actually follows the principle
识别它更困难的事情。或者我需要能够在新的伪装下识别它吗？那更困难。所以拿那个关于足球的问题和那个关于汽车的问题。把那两个表面看起来不同的问题拿出来，然后描述它们实际上是如何相似的？尚卡尔，这实际上遵循了
that you and I have been talking about before, which is that memory sort of follows thought. What you're getting yourself to do by comparing those problems is thinking about what they have in common, you're thinking about that deep structure that they share. And so that's gonna make you better appreciate that deep structure and be able to
你和我之前一直在谈论的原则，即记忆在某种程度上跟随思维。通过比较这些问题，你让自己做的是思考它们的共同点，你是在思考它们共享的深层结构。所以这会让你更好地欣赏那种深层结构，并能够在
Remember it and recognize it later in new problems You know so much of what we've been talking about I think goes back to that idea of Almost probing our minds to find You know the weaknesses to find the broken links in the chain. And that is just so hard to do, isn't it? Because it's sort of constantly exposing us to the limits of our own knowledge, the limits of our own understanding. It's forcing us to do the difficult thing of doing, you know, the push-ups where you're trying to clap as you're doing the push-ups. I think I'm
以后在新的问题中记住并识别它。你知道，我们一直在谈论的很多内容，我认为都回到了那种几乎是在探测我们的大脑以寻找你知道的弱点，寻找链条中断裂环节的想法。这真的很难做到，不是吗？因为它在某种程度上不断地让我们暴露在自己知识的局限性、自己理解的局限性之下。它强迫我们做困难的事情，你知道，就像你在做俯卧撑时试图拍手一样。我想我
trying to intuit why it is so many of us not only have bad memories, but why it's so difficult to fix those bad memories. It's just effortful, and I think it's hard to face up to it. It's not fun to say like, oh, there's a whole lot here that I don't know. There's a whole lot. Let me make a point of probing what I don't know. Let me find my weaknesses. That takes ego strength to sort of be brave in that way and look at what we don't know, let me find my weaknesses, that takes ego strength to sort of be brave in that way and look at what we don't know.
试图直觉地理解为什么我们这么多人不仅记忆力不好，而且为什么修复那些糟糕的记忆力如此困难。这只是费力，而且我认为很难面对它。说“哦，这里有很多我不知道的东西”并不有趣。有很多。让我重点探测我不知道的东西。让我找到我的弱点。这需要自我力量才能以那种方式勇敢起来，看看我们不知道的东西，让我找到我的弱点，这需要自我力量才能以那种方式勇敢起来，看看我们不知道的东西。
So even when we use very rigorous memory strategies, our memories may still fail us. And you have learned to use external aids to help your memory. I understand that in fact, you might be a little obsessed with calendars and alarms. Can you tell me about your various practices involving calendars and alarms, Dan? Yeah, I'm obsessed is probably fair. My perspective memory is not very good.
所以即使我们使用非常严格的记忆策略，我们的记忆可能仍然会让我们失望。你已经学会使用外部辅助工具来帮助你的记忆。我了解到事实上，你可能对日历和闹钟有点着迷。你能告诉我你涉及日历和闹钟的各种做法吗，丹？是的，说我着迷可能很公平。我的前瞻性记忆不太好。
I don't remember to do things. And so the way I deal with that is I've made a real habit of relying on my calendar. And if it's not on my calendar, the odds that I'm going to remember it are very, very close to zero. And I also make heavy use of alarms that are programmed in my phone. In a typical day, I'll have eight alarms or something like that going. So you have something going off at 11.25 to tell you something's happening at 11.30, pay attention?
我不记得要做什么。所以我处理这个问题的方法是，我养成了一个真正依赖日历的习惯。如果它不在我的日历上，我能记住它的几率非常非常接近于零。我也大量使用手机里设置的闹钟。在典型的一天里，我会设置八个左右的闹钟。所以你在11:25会有闹钟响，告诉你11:30有事发生，注意一下？
Yeah, I mean, again, this is sort of facing up to weakness. I just live too much in my head, and I'm not aware enough of the world around me, and so I need something to sort of snap me out of it. I understand that this habit of relying on external memory saved the day for you at one point a few years ago. Tell me that story, Dan. This was five years ago maybe, and my wife had our three children out. They were all at an event that I was not at. This was on a Sunday. So this is pretty unusual for me with three small children. And so I was really enjoying myself. I'm sort of puttering around the house and doing little chores as we do on Sunday. And then I start to decide I'm
是的，我的意思是，这又是在面对弱点。我只是太沉浸在自己的思想里了，我对周围的世界不够了解，所以我需要一些东西来让我从中跳出来。我了解到这种依赖外部记忆的习惯在几年前的一次关键时刻拯救了你。告诉我那个故事，丹。那可能是五年前，我妻子带着我们的三个孩子出去了。他们都在一个我没参加的活动上。那是在一个星期天。所以这对我来说带着三个小孩是很不寻常的。所以我当时真的很享受。我正在家里四处走动，做些小家务，就像我们在星期天做的那样。然后我开始决定我
going to do a little work puttering. So I start answering email and so on. And then at some point I get an email where I need to put something in my calendar. So I open my calendar and I still remember the feeling of opening my calendar and perceiving on that day a red blob. Red means important and is one of those things where like time slows down and I'm like that can't be right and I go and look at what it is and I realize I have an airplane I'm supposed to be on't be right. And I go and look at what it is. And I realize I have an airplane I'm supposed to be on in 75 minutes. Oh my God.
要处理一点工作。所以我开始回复电子邮件等等。然后在某个时候，我收到一封邮件，我需要把某件事放进我的日历里。所以我打开了我的日历，我仍然记得打开日历并感知到那天有一个红色的斑点。红色意味着重要，这是那种时间变慢的事情之一，我想“那不可能是真的”，我去看看那是什么，我意识到我有一架飞机要在75分钟后搭乘。天哪。
And the airplane, I was supposed to go to city in the Midwest and I was supposed to give a talk the next day. I wasn't packed. I had absolutely no idea what the talk was supposed to be that I was supposed to give. The airport's about a half an hour away. Oh my God. So for my life, I threw
那架飞机，我本来要去中西部的一个城市，我本来要在第二天做一个演讲。我还没打包。我完全不知道我应该做的演讲是什么。机场大约半小时路程。天哪。所以为了我的生活，我扔
things in a suitcase and it all ended up fine, but that was a very close call. Daniel Willingham is a psychologist at the University of Virginia. He's the author of the book, Outsmart Your Brain While Learning is Hard and How You Can Make It easy. Dan, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been a real pleasure. Thank you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer.
东西进手提箱，最后一切都很好，但那是一次非常惊险的经历。丹尼尔·威林厄姆是弗吉尼亚大学的心理学家。他是《智胜你的大脑：学习很难，你可以让它变得简单》一书的作者。丹，非常感谢你今天加入Hidden Brain。这真是一种荣幸。谢谢。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。
I'm Hiddenbrain's executive editor. We end today with a story from our sister show, My Unsung Hero. This My Unsung Hero segment is brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. Our story comes from Sabrina Kronk. 20 years ago, Sabrina was a newly single mother living near Nashville.
我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。今天我们以我们姐妹节目《我无名的英雄》中的一个故事结束。这个《我无名的英雄》片段由T-Mobile for Business赞助。我们的故事来自萨布丽娜·克朗克。20年前，萨布丽娜是一位住在纳什维尔附近的单身母亲。
Things were tough financially, but she just landed a new job and life was looking up. That is, until one fall morning, when she got into her car to take her daughter to daycare, and the car wouldn't start. I had a Jeep Grand Cherokee that had over 250,000 miles, and I walked out to my car, put my three and a half year old daughter in her car seat, jumped in the front seat, and put the keys in the ignition, tried to turn the keys,
经济上很困难，但她刚找到一份新工作，生活正在好转。也就是直到一个秋天的早晨，当她上车带女儿去托儿所时，车发动不起来了。我有一辆行驶里程超过25万英里的吉普大切诺基，我走到车前，把三岁半的女儿放进安全座椅，跳进前座，把钥匙插进点火开关，试图转动钥匙，
and immediately heard this clicking noise. And, you know, my heart just sunk. I thought, what is wrong now? I had had my car in the shop multiple times over the past couple of weeks and months. Finances were just so limited at that point. And I'd already been pouring a lot of money into the car. The car eventually rumbled to a start. And I knew I had to drive
立刻听到了这种咔哒声。你知道，我的心沉了下去。我想，现在又怎么了？过去几周和几个月里，我的车多次进过修理厂。当时经济状况非常有限。而且我已经往车里投入了很多钱。车最终轰鸣着启动了。我知道我必须开车
straight to the service center at the car dealership and not stop anywhere else. So I could get there in one piece and hopefully wouldn't break down on the side of the road. So we drove straight to the dealership, pulled into the service bay and the service technicians started taking out my daughter's car seat and putting it in the courtesy car that would drive us to her daycare and work. And I realized they had done it so many times that it was like we had our own personal pit crew. You know, you pull in and they start taking care of things without even being told what to do. They
直接去汽车经销商的服务中心，不能在任何其他地方停留。这样我才能完整地到达那里，希望不会在路边抛锚。所以我们直接开车去了经销商处，开进了服务区，维修技术人员开始把女儿的安全座椅拿出来，放进送我们去托儿所和工作的礼宾车里。我意识到他们已经做过很多次了，就像我们有自己的私人维修团队一样。你知道，你开进去，他们就开始处理事情，甚至不需要被告知该做什么。他们
just knew to transfer everything. They would even shuttle us to the front of the line. Like they didn't want her to have to wait or me to have to wait. Drove me to her daycare and then I'll walk to work, which wasn't far, and so at the end of the day they called me, told me the courtesy car was on the way and that it would be ready when I got there that afternoon to pick up. So I'll walk up to the cashier after we arrived and she told me there was no charge. They had miraculously found the part I needed at no cost. And I said, could you check that?
只是知道要转移所有东西。他们甚至会把我们送到队伍的最前面。就像他们不想让她等待，也不想让我等待一样。把我送到她的托儿所，然后我步行去上班，离得不远，所以那天结束时他们给我打电话，告诉我礼宾车在路上了，下午我去接的时候它就准备好了。所以我到达后走到收银台，她告诉我没有收费。他们奇迹般地找到了我需要的零件，没有花钱。我说，你能核实一下吗？
Like, what is the labor cost gonna be today? And she said that the service technicians had donated their labor. And I just couldn't believe what I was hearing. So I asked her if she would please check with a manager. I just wanted to make sure. And he came over to me and just told me just to not worry about it. Everything was taken care of just to focus on taking care of my daughter.
就像，今天的劳务费是多少？她说维修技术人员捐赠了他们的劳动。我简直不敢相信我听到的。所以我问她是否能请她和经理核实一下。我只是想确保一下。他走到我身边，只是告诉我不用担心。一切都处理好了，只要专注于照顾我的女儿就行了。
I could barely speak. Tears filled my eyes. And he ushered me quickly in my car and then kind of gave me two taps on the on the top of the car like, let's go. I'll just never forget that kindness and generosity. I mean in them doing that it made it possible for us to survive financially the rest of the month. Whenever I think about that time in my life, I think about not only that crew,
我几乎说不出话来。泪水涌上我的眼眶。他迅速把我带到车里，然后在车顶上拍了两下，就像说“走吧”。我永远不会忘记那种善良和慷慨。我的意思是，他们这样做使我们能够在那个月的剩余时间里在经济上生存下来。每当我想到我生命中的那段时间，我不仅想到那个团队，
but all the other people that helped us. Just having that kind of kindness in a moment where you're like, what now? What else do I have to deal with? They say when you're at the end of your lifeline, tie a piece of string on it and hang on. Well, they allowed me to do that that day. Sabrina Kronk of Nashville, Tennessee. Her daughter, Katie, is now an adult.
还想到所有其他帮助过我们的人。在那种你觉得“现在怎么办？我还要处理什么？”的时刻，拥有那种善良。人们说当你处于生命线的尽头时，系上一根绳子并坚持住。好吧，那天他们让我做到了。纳什维尔的萨布丽娜·克朗克。她的女儿凯蒂现在已经成年了。
This segment of My Unsung Hero was brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. Next week, we conclude this year's U2.0 series with a look at cynicism. So it's almost as though if social connection is medicine, it doesn't work for cynics. It's almost as though they're resistant to this medication that helps the rest of us. How cynicism harms us and how to resist its pull, that's next week in the final episode of our series. If you missed any part of today's show or any of our U2.0 episodes, you can find them in this podcast feed or at hiddenbrain.org. Today's episode is the one titled U2.0 Remember More, Forget Less.
《我无名的英雄》这一片段由T-Mobile for Business赞助。下周，我们将通过审视愤世嫉俗来结束今年的U2.0系列。所以这几乎就像如果社会联系是良药，它对愤世嫉俗者不起作用。这几乎就像他们对这种帮助我们其他人的药物有抵抗力一样。愤世嫉俗如何伤害我们以及如何抵制它的吸引力，这就是我们系列最后一集的下周内容。如果你错过了今天节目的任何部分或我们的任何U2.0剧集，你可以在这个播客订阅源或hiddenbrain.org上找到它们。今天的剧集标题是《U2.0 记住更多，遗忘更少》。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。你 这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。